[Music]
he is a Joe LM beat of my 76ers love his
style not afraid to shoot a three not
afraid to light up Twitter as well and
we got to get him into the all-star game
we trust the process with Joe LMB who
joins us how are you this morning where
are you right now I'm on my way to the
practice facility we got practice in the
barn and now what do you listen in on
the way to our practice is wicked my
future and I listen to it all the time
and every time I score basket there
always stays at the arena so that's a
favor so I like that but didn't you have
this Twitter crush on Rihanna years ago
have you moved on from Rihanna is that
what you're saying we all do nothing
wrong with that how important is making
the all-star team here I think is very
important especially for mainly for the
city of Philadelphia you know kind of
bling you know that's I think that's
gonna bring some kind of joy back to the
fans I don't be rewarded you know the
past three years they've been going to a
lot of losing so having someone that
can't go on we present them and the
Austin I think is gonna be picked up if
your nickname wasn't the process what
would it be
did you have one in Kansas yeah I can't
just they call me the lion killer
have you actually killed a lion joelle
yeah yeah yeah give me the story I had
to go in the jungle to turn the line so
that was a way for me to prove that I
was a bad man but I was also with for me
to become a man so I went into the
jungle
I had a spear and I toured to another
line and he fell asleep and I just came
back oh and then I carried the lion on
my back back to the village candid when
I got to the village that was just I
proved that I was abandoned because I
became appearances all six years old
wait you're six years old you kill a
lion you bring the line back to the
village now are there six-year-olds who
go into the jungle and don't come back
as they're trying to be a man can't so
I've always thought my whole life so I
think he was the easy job has anybody
else on the 76ers killed a lion okay
yeah I would imagine when that topic
comes up then nobody else can offer up
anything
I was curious how how important was
soccer to you because I looked at Hakeem
Olajuwon and his footwork is maybe the
best footwork I ever saw on a big man
but he attributed that to playing soccer
how important is soccer to you what is
there the body that I think he played a
huge role especially for my footwork in
the place my whole life and having that
type of food walk on the soccer field I
think is up especially for someone like
me and you know we gotta got the same
story started saying basketball I
started basketball
when I was 16 years old so I think you
helped us a lot and that was it wasn't
just it wasn't just soccer I used to
play volleyball you know assault having
a cognition to go up and down jump up
and down yeah I think he's also helping
bit
he's Joelle embiid he's averaging almost
20 points per game seven and a half
rebounds put up 21 and 14 last night
against the Knicks what do you think of
porzingis I think he had a wart but you
know he's had a great year really well
and I like his game he's one of the
young up-and-coming big man in the
league so I like his game he can do
everything on a call put on the floor
host he's a great defender too so I
think he's got it got it all our best
player you've faced assumed popular bond
James son game you know we rewarded set
them twice we were pretty close we we
had the lead in both games
we shouldn't want those two but I'd say
LeBron was probably the best operator
would you rather be in the dunk contest
or the three-point shooting contest oh
okay I think I can do both this year
I've been going okay Joelle I have a
great idea here you have to be at least
seven feet tall to be in the three-point
shooting contest so only seven footers
are going to be in the three-point
shooting contest what do you think to
add some more seconds you know we don't
usually big men we don't have that quick
release as girls do so I think they're
gonna have to add a couple seconds but I
think you can do it
yes we can do that lately several
footers I'll be shooting a lot of trees
and making them so that wouldn't be a
bad idea could you beat Nowitzki oh I
don't I don't think so I don't know I
think I can this is one of the greatest
shooters of all time so yeah I think I
can't keep up but I'm not sure well
congrats on the season so far and
hopefully you get into the all-star game
it's been fun to watch you finally get a
chance to play and prove that you
deserve to be picked that high and we
trusted the process thanks for joining
us Joelle yeah yes thanks for joining us
thank you thank you okay that's Joelle
embiid he killed a lion what did you do
when you were six years old the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]